hey las vegas now snacking gets a bad
rap but it shouldn't snacking can be a
smart way to help fill in nutrient gaps
keep energy levels up and support weight
management today i have healthy snack
ideas for sweet and savory lovers
including homemade snack boxes and
grab-and-go options first what makes up
a healthy snack a healthy snack should
be low in added sugar fat and sodium and
instead focused on protein and fiber
which will keep you satisfied and
energized between meals there are many
grab-and-go dietitian approved options
for when you need something quick and
easy such as freeze-dried fruit with a
handful of nuts hummus with sliced
veggies or salsa with chips like the new
atkins protein chips which have 13 grams
of protein per bag and 4 grams of fiber
they come in nacho cheese and ranch with
the salty savory crunchy wanton chips
but without the carbs find them at
walmart walmart.com next up we have
satisfying sweet and savory snack boxes
four ways to make a mediterranean snack
box add whole grain pita sliced cucumber
and cherry tomatoes olives almonds and
hummus i use the new creamy fresh
cravings hummus because it's made with a
short list of high quality whole food
ingredients like chilean extra virgin
olive oil chickpeas and savory tahini
you can find the classic roasted red
pepper and roasted garlic flavors at
walmart for this salsa snack box add
sliced bell peppers a hard boiled egg
protein chips and salsa the fresh
cravings salsa is refrigerated instead
of jarred you can find the chunky and
restaurant style salsa in a range of
heat levels chilled in the produce
section at walmart if you're craving
sweet over savory simply swap out
veggies in your snack box for fruit
which just like veggies is a source of
fiber vitamins minerals and antioxidants
to make this chocolate yogurt box whisk
together a third cup of plain greek
yogurt with one teaspoon of honey and
one teaspoon of cocoa powder add whole
grain low sugar granola walnuts and
fruit the 100 pure freeze dried fruit
snacks by crispy green are a fun way to
help meet your recommended one and a
half to two cup daily servings made with
just one ingredient fruit and no added
sugar for this peanut butter dipper box
add peanut butter dark chocolate whole
grain crackers and freeze-dried
strawberry and pineapple crispy fruit
the light and crispy texture makes them
perfect for snacking and dipping and
they come in eight varieties including
tangerine apple banana and mango find
them at albertsons and big lots i hope
you enjoyed these healthy snacking tips
for more snack ideas nutrition tips and
healthy recipes you can visit my website
nutritionbymia.com
and instagram nutritionbymia
dr nash and